I'm Jeff Jarvis a blog at buzz machine
comment eats journalist mikuni and my
part of the world what we need to do to
change the world for innovation is to
get in entrepreneurship I think the
future is entrepreneurial more than
institutional the institutions which are
pretty much here at Davos are the ones
that are disrupted we need to bring
together the disruptors and to find ways
to support them I teach entrepreneurial
journalism at CUNY which is not owned
oxymoron and I think we have to bring
entrepreneurship too many industries and
to enable the future to be built it can
be painful but let's get there faster
than later